- My art is very much so focused
on my own struggles with mental illness,
both as a coping mechanism
but also as a way to kind of articulate
very precisely how I feel
in a way that's not verbal.
(gentle music)
My name is Panteha Abareshi.
I have sickle cell zero beta thalassemia.
It's a genetic blood condition.
My mom had an
unexpressed gene for sickle cell.
And my dad had an unexpressed
gene for thalassemia.
And I got the least likely but
worst combination of genes,
where I have both of them expressed.
So, I have both of the diseases.
The pain aspect of it
comes from the blood cells
getting caught between
my bones or sickling.
And creating this pain response
that can manifest in
bones, joints, nerves.
When I turned 14, the
pain, all of a sudden,
became much more severe and constant.
So, it was a big change
to all of a sudden,
like not having the pain ever subside
and to kind of learn
how to live with that.
I was like isolated and in
the hospital all the time,
at home all the time.
When my pain started getting really bad
and my depression and anxiety
started getting really bad,
I kind of lost all of the things
that I liked to do or the things
that I would turn to for coping.
Whether it was like reading books
or even listening to music or watching TV.
It just kind of would like be just noise
that I couldn't really focus on or enjoy.
I never just like picked up
a pen and a piece of paper
and been like, "I'm gonna just draw."
So, (laughs) when I started doing that,
it was like the most amazing feeling.
I need something, you know,
obviously like everyone does,
when you're in pain to distract you.
But my art, I really quickly realized
was what I needed to cope
with my mental illness
that was very, very intense.
My sickle cell, like,
people actually understand
and are actively trying to help me.
And with my mental illness,
people are like, "Well,
I don't see the symptoms,
"then I don't care and you're better."
Honestly, it all comes
back down to the fact
that it's so stigmatized
and misunderstood.
(gentle music)
Creating my art for myself,
and not for anyone else is
like consumption, really.
Like, I'm not putting it out there
expecting people to like
it or to want to see more.
And all the girls that I
draw, like they love roses.
Roses is kind of like this weapon almost.
Like, the things that are like spiney.
Like, you could like cut someone with it
or you know, impale someone with it.
When I draw my girls, or
the people that I draw,
and they are in pain, the literal sense,
like the physical sense of pain.
Where there's like a knife in their neck
or like a rose poking through their hand.
Or like they're squeezing a rose so hard
that blood's dripping down their hands.
Or like, they have a bloody nose.
Or like, they're bleeding
from their mouth.
Like, things that you associate with,
"Whoa, something's wrong."
Like, "That must've really hurt."
Like, all of these things
that are painful, dangerous.
Like, you look at them and you're like,
"Ow, that looks like it really hurts."
Those are me
expressing what my
mental illness feels like
in ways that people can like take in
and understand a degree of pain.
Creating something
tangible out of something
that is like hyper intangible.
To share a pain or to like
share a sensation like that,
like a hurt sensation,
it makes people feel uncomfortable
and it makes people feel vulnerable.
And that's what I think
we need people to feel
in order for them to understand
honestly what mental illness is like.
And to like make a
change and move forward.
(gentle music)
(sign squeaks)